映画君の名はおめてきました
ぶっちゃけよかったーーーぐ思い出さちょっと泣けてくるんですけどなんかハグラー
なっちゃうじゃない機関へのってなんかすごいやばいのが出たみたいなハードルが
上がって実際どうなんだか撮って見に行ったらハードルをすごいちゃんと超えてきて
くださって
本当に観てよかったなって思いました皆さんぜひ見に行ってください
えっと北アンチャーですねだいぶフェアウェイは綺麗なんですよこの深くで部屋の外
綺麗だなっていうかもわかると思うんですけどもう軍事にはまだちょっと汚いところが
ありますそれがこちら
姉の地下につながる階段ですここ基本的に土足なんでその後回いつも口で歩いてるん
ですけどやっぱりぞとでこっちつとか
ここ
おりとかいろんな5面がたくさんついてですごい汚いんですよねこのまま掃除しても
もったいないと思ったんで滝を作ろうかなと思いました間の上から水をめちゃくちゃ
流せば水で全部おっしゃるってを流れていくわけじゃないですか水が流れで汚れとかも
全部遊び倒していくんじゃないかなと思ったので今回は家の中で書を作ってみようと
思いますでもうちょい遊び半分じゃないんだよって普通に掃除ですけど掃除どうですか
いたで滝を流すんですけどもどうせなら俳壇の汚れと一緒に心の汚れも落としてしまう
と思いましてアダンティーズの空人がもうすぐ者に行きますあの子は心がもう汚れ
ちゃってるので
それぞれの心の汚れもねちょっとついでに夫してあげようかなと思ったのでそれ血が
上ってくれて改ざんの下にいた瞬間にそれにあって卓球を流してパティの心の汚れよ
洗い流してあげようかなと思っております猫日本にずれて r でいいんですか
yeah yeah
amaran
goo
ええええええ
me
はいの時受けて水を準備しました
多分普通にこれで階段は急になるのねあとはこの水の量で育ちの心まで花井落とせるか
がポイントになります階段の掃除機をかけましょう
それに暑いっ
とはどこですか少し安いやつん
[音楽]
はあああっ
笑ところじゃんっ
純粋に楽しめません
[音楽]
文通ん
宝木ソナー
さあ時じゃないところを払え待ってるよ私
ああああああああああああ
ni nare
ana ああああ
ここが流れません
開き方をはじめ
ああああああああ
足跡をはじめ開き方をはじめ
秋彼等ありがとう足跡をはじめ
マフィアとをはじめハリー